[Applause]
but we can't get those things on our own
raul helped build this organization
with the understanding that the
diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
[Applause]
is your strength
what up yo i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report it's july 12 2022 we're
live streaming on rumble youtube ablaze
tv and the woman that you just saw right
there in the cold open is the wife of
the man pretending to be president that
is dr
jill biden she is a doctor you must
refer to her as a doctor apparently she
has not examined her husband but she is
dr jill biden and in that uh little
snippet that we just showed you she was
talking to a bunch of latino and latina
people or as the left calls them the
tinx people and she was comparing their
diversity to tacos
pandering is in even the word that
should be used when it comes to the
democrats and minorities oh you're like
a little pork taco and you over there
you're like a little chicken taco oh a
little fried fish taco
connor you love the tacos what kind of
taco do you consider latino people to be
carne asada well played my friend well
played uh guys we have a huge show for
you today this might be the biggest show
we've ever done i think we possibly have
more clips in this show than we've ever
had uh it's so it's a big day around
here and we're shifting the focus a
little bit it's not going to be exactly
sort of the uh
the crazy twitter stuff that we've been
doing and and some of the florida stuff
that we've been doing and that we're
shifting a little bit towards this new
world order thing uh because we touched
on this i haven't done too much on this
this great reset thing and this new
world order thing and this world
economic forum thing we've touched on a
little bit i i did a little something on
the friday panel a couple days ago about
klaus schwab and the world economic
forum and the video caught fire which
sends a signal to us that oh our
audience is interested in this sort of
thing and who are the bad guys in
society these days sure we can mock the
democrats all day but maybe there's a
much more nefarious force
behind them that explains some of the
insanity that we're all uh going through
right now so we're going to talk about
the world economic forum in this new
world order there's some crazy
crazy protests that you are definitely
not seeing on mainstream news happening
in the netherlands
right now these dutch farmers that are
protesting some of the government
policies and this stuff
is being coordinated all over the world
when we see truckers uprising in canada
and we see farmers uprise in the
netherlands there are reasons that these
things are happening and some of those
reasons are actually leaking into the
mainstream where people are starting to
talk about it so the stuff that we're
going to talk about today is the stuff
that they're going to be talking about
uh on the mainstream media in probably
about four months or so so it's a very
international show for you so it is nice
that we started with the taco thing
because it's an international program
for you uh reminder guys real quick if
you want to see me this week two days
from today july 14th with ron desantis
press secretary christina pusha my buddy
dave reboy and fox news correspondent
lisa booth uh there are a couple tickets
left you can go to davereuben.com
events and see me at the improv oh and
then i got a couple other florida things
this month i will be at the sunshine
summit i'm hosting co-hosting with lisa
booth again
the sunshine summit here in fort
lauderdale i believe that is on the 23rd
of july and then the next day i got to
get in the car and drive all the way
across florida i will be in tampa for
the turning point student action summit
with governor desantis and president
trump and greg gutfeld and ted cruz and
a whole bunch of other people so we will
be seeing you good people before we get
to the big show let me talk to you about
expressvpn real quick do you know that
big uh tech and big government have
something in common they both want to
silence any dissenting voices into
submission
this show will be very much about that
uh let's say you're a proud gun owner
and want to talk on social media about
the right to bear arms well chances are
that your post will be flagged by a
content moderator and you might end up
on some kind of government watch list to
fight back against having your voice
censored by big tech and big government
i recommend using expressvpn when i use
expressvpn they can't see my ip address
my identity is anonymized by a secure
vpn server plus expressvpn encrypts 100
of my internet data for protection for
uh for protection from hackers and
eavesdroppers expressvpn is by far the
best vpn i've tried it's the number one
rated vpn by business insider and
countless other tech publications and
what i love most about expressvpn is it
couldn't be easier to use the app has
one button you tap it and you're good to
go it's that simple so stop letting big
tech and big government censor and track
you defend your rights and protect
yourself at expressvpn.com
ruben that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vbn.com ruben to get three
months absolutely free visit expressvpn
to learn more alright so let's talk
about some of the bad guys in the world
right now we often hear these phrases
the globalists the great reset the world
economic forum and it's like they're
these sort of amorphous things and these
government leaders get together in these
very fancy places in the alps and in the
mountains and these remote areas and
they talk about all of us and then we
hear little trickles of it online but
it's like what is all of
this stuff well klaus schwab
who comes off as a evil cartoon
character is the head of the world
economic forum and he is the main driver
of this new world order that these
people want to put in now i'm not being
a conspiracy theorist when i say it we
are going to show you plenty of video of
them talking about their new world order
and of course they want to bring us a
new world order because you know the
planet's going to explode because of
climate change and there's an awful lot
of you people sharing misinformation
to limit global warming
you are demanding to help to coal
oil and gas exploration
to the development
and to the financing of this exploration
as well
you are asking firms to replace any
corporate board directors who is
unwilling to transition to clean energy
sources
you are championing an open internet and
a 2 trillion digital access plan
to bring the world online
and prevent internet shutdowns
and you are presenting new ways
to minimize the spread of misinformation
and you want to combat
dangerous extremist views in the
internet
okay so klaus schwab right there is
talking to world leaders and he's
talking to corporate leaders about what
they have to do related to climate
change and misinformation now you might
say but wait a minute i elect leaders in
my country countries are supposed to be
sovereign what
is it that this guy has over these
people who is he and what right does he
have to be telling world leaders what
they have to do related to climate
change or misinformation or anything
else of course what's interesting there
there are two lines that really struck
at me there he says that uh that they
should replace corporate leaders that
was the phrase to use replace corporate
leaders who basically won't play along
with their climate change agenda again
who
is he what is the world economic forum
why would it have the right to tell a
company what policies that that company
should have but they they have their
tentacles sort of in everything then he
also talks about an open internet and
it's hilarious because he's talking
about an open internet internet that'll
avoid shutdowns and everything but we
also have to watch out for
misinformation so the very same people
who would love to silence all of us are
the ones that are always talking about
an open internet because irony is truly
dead but this is a guy who has extremely
powerful friends in all parts of
government all over the world so this is
going to shift us a little bit to what's
going on in the netherlands right now uh
schwab schwab is a big fan of dutch
prime minister mark rutt uh he says he's
his favorite world leader and there's a
lot of weird stuff happening in the
netherlands right now take a look
where do you find still such a prime
minister in the world
you find it in the netherlands
and it's mark huerta we should not
underestimate
the significant role the netherlands is
playing on the international scene
you are one of the mcdonald's
you are at the forefront
in terms of cyber security of food
security
walter
gender
and so on but i was told
by
a nonsecretive source
you are also
probably the best looking
prime minister in
in
in in europe
you are a compass man
someone
who has clear values
who follows his values
so you are real statesman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so klaus schwab really has a boner
for this marc rutay guy who is the prime
minister of the netherlands uh did you
catch the line in there uh that the
netherlands holland is on the forefront
of food security water and gender
do you see how they combine these things
the netherlands is on the forefront of
gender
what does that mean who the hell knows
nobody knows but they combine all these
things and then they think that they're
good people but anyway he really loves
this guy and he's a good looking dude
and he's doing all the stuff that we
want him to do
but not so what is the stuff that they
want him to do and is everyone uh in the
netherlands happy about it well here is
a dutch mp a dutch member of parliament
uh i may butcher his name slightly his
name is gideon van meeren
and he's exposing in parliament mark
rutte for his relationship with klaus
schwab and how that is ushering the
great reset into the netherlands right
now
at world economic forum and i've talked
about
um
okay so this is a rather extraordinary
exchange and i know we don't talk about
the netherlands that much on this
country actually i love the netherlands
i've been about four or five times i
have family in the netherlands uh i love
amsterdam as a city it's it's a
wonderful country
but there's something really interesting
here so here you have a young member of
parliament basically saying to the prime
minister uh you're a sellout there is
this other organization that has nothing
to do or should have nothing to do with
how we are governed and you seem to be
very much in bed with this guy klaus
schwab in the world economic forum and
you've responded via a letter to say how
influential this book is sort of on your
thinking well uh gideon
continues to go after rutay
okay so this really is something i know
this is little off the beaten path for
what we normally do here but this really
is something and and i think you'll see
why in the next clip
that this great reset that seems to be
happening the upheaval that seems to be
happening the inept world leaders who
seem to be destroying things and and
reversing all of the known world and
unearthing all of this stuff that we had
put to bed there's a reason for it it is
because of this great reset through the
world economic forum and this klaus
schwab guy i am this is not like some
crazy conspiracy stuff it is now
becoming law
in the netherlands so so this brings us
to what is happening right now there is
a massive country-wide protest happening
in the netherlands right now because
dutch farmers have had it with the
policies of mark rutte who is the prime
minister who is putting in all of these
policies that are harming the energy
sector and making the farmers lives much
more difficult causing the prices of
food to go up etc etc this is very
similar uh to what we had happen in
canada not too long ago here's some
video about what's going on with the
dutch farmers
and in the netherlands farmers are
staging nationwide process after
government's decision to cut down on its
emissions of nitrogen oxide and ammonia
by 2030. the decision has resulted to
cause discomfort in the netherlands
lucrative agriculture sector
the dutch government decided to slash 50
of its nitrogen emissions by 2030 and
has set aside an extra fund of 25.6
billion us dollars to make the necessary
changes but this decision has sparked a
nationwide protest by the farmers
agitated farmers believe
the target is unfeasible and will only
threaten their livelihood moreover
farmers across the country held mass
demonstrations and blocked highways with
their tractors while few of them had a
scaffold with police officials just
outside the home of minister in charge
of government's nitrogen policy
okay so this is rather extraordinary
stuff and you can see what's going on
here imagine telling a bunch of farmers
you have to reduce your emissions by 50
by 2030 in eight years it is completely
untenable the the farmers then who are
producing all of the food for the
country and if i'm not mistaken the
netherlands is one of the biggest food
exporters uh in the entire world
the farmers are saying hey we can't do
it and then then they're doing what they
have a right to do in a western society
which is protest now the question is why
is the prime minister day of the
netherlands doing this is he doing this
because he thinks this is the right
thing for netherlands to turn against
the farmers and put these unattainable
goals related to emissions out there or
is it because he is a tool a tool or a
stooge
of
klaus schwab and the world economic
forum so here is some video of the
protest because the people are with the
farmers surprise surprise
this is true
a village in the dutch province of
gelderland in central netherlands
thousands of farmers have assembled
protested against the government's
far-reaching plants to cut nitrogen
emissions
this is one of the largest ever
demonstrations by the farmers
they're driving in with their tractors
blowing horns and causing widespread
traffic cures
the dutch farmers are demanding the
scrapping of recently announced plans by
the hague-based government
they believe it could see a 30 reduction
in livestock
i love that the woman in the report she
goes they're causing wide spread traffic
chaos they show one guy at a truck
driving across an open field but the
point is joking aside that these are
farmers who are saying hey we we just
want a farm we would like to grow say
flowers they do a lot and a lot of that
in the netherlands but we also grow all
sorts of food and spices and all sorts
of vegetables and things and peppers and
broccoli etc and we would like to
continue to be able to do that but our
own prime minister is making that very
hard
because of this guy klaus schwab who is
an unelected globalist bureaucrat he is
not in charge of any government but
don't those videos right there when you
see those people out there and you see
truckers of course they're being painted
as far right and they're racist and all
those things but doesn't it just remind
you of what happened just a few months
ago in canada when a bunch of truckers
said hey no more you cannot force us to
get vaccinated you cannot force us to
stay in our homes and everything else
and then the machine
makes it seem like these are the bad
guys the people who just want to live
their lives put food on the table go to
work et cetera et cetera so we'll get to
the north american response to all of
this in just a second because it's
leaking here too i hate to tell you but
real quick guys let me talk about real
estate agents i trust you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment and that's a ton of
responsibility so you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
founded by my good buddy glenn beck they
work with only the best agents in every
market they do their homework
and talk to every agent before asking
them to join their network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the introduction
and then follows you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied the agents they work
with have long track records are the
best sellers in their field they're part
of this audience they share your values
and they're almost anywhere you want to
go including miami florida the process
is simple just go to real estate
agentsidetrust.com today and provide
them with some basic info they'll reach
out to you connect you with a preferred
agent then you live happily ever
after okay so let's continue
talking about this klaus schwab
and what he is pushing
on all of the western nations across the
world it's not just that he wants them
to watch out for climate change and
change their policies for climate change
which then affects their economies and
it's not just that he wants them to be
watching out for misinformation and what
he means by misinformation is just
information that goes against what he in
the world economic forum wants uh it's
also
surprise surprise about kovid and
vaccine coercion
here he is a little while ago
trying to scare the hell out of you
about maxine's
what should you do differently
most immediately
you are calling for the international
community
to safeguard vaccine equity
to respond to copy 19
and prevent future health crisis
nobody will be safe
if not everybody is vaccinated
nobody will safe will be safe if not
everybody is vaccinated wouldn't that
imply guys i'm not a scientist or a
biologist but wouldn't that imply that
the vaccine doesn't work
nobody will be safe if everyone isn't
vaccinated i'm pretty sure
uh that if a vaccine worked meaning you
would not get the thing that you were
vaccinated for that's the way vaccines
worked before kobit uh that
if you were vaccinated and somebody else
wasn't and the vaccine worked you
wouldn't get sick they would and
everybody would be okay but we know the
vaccines don't work as promised we know
they don't stop covid they don't stop
you from getting covered they don't stop
you from transmitting copen but why is
it that this man wants everyone to be
injected with this experimental mrna
vaccine well you're not gonna believe it
one of his best buddies this is
craziness guys this is this is going to
knock you out of your chair one of klaus
schwab's best buddies happens to be
pfizer ceo albert borla
and uh they don't really like you guys
because you guys say mean things about
them and don't always
do exactly what they want
with the vaccine
that we knew that there is a very
fanatic group of anti-vaxxers
that will go after us no matter what
they will claim that the sun didn't go
up because people were vaccinated and
that created issues with the crop so i'm
seeing you we were both targets of c and
t
vaccine movements and conspiracy
people
claiming that i had tripled i wonder
what it is
triple um
kovid
so even though that guy
the ceo of pfizer lied the entire time
and joe biden lied and anthony fauci
lied and walensky over at the cdc lied
all lying about whether the vaccines
worked or not and what boosters were
doing and all of these things even
though they lied about everything there
was no evidence for lockdowns that any
of this works even social distancing
doesn't necessarily work we know now we
now know masks don't work i mean they
lied about absolutely everything but if
you questioned these unelected
bureaucrats these people who run the cdc
and the guy who runs the world economic
forum if you question them you're a
conspiracy theorist you're an
anti-vaxxer you know it's funny when i
hear someone say anti-vaxxer now because
i never had an issue with vaccines in my
entire life it's not something that i've
put a tremendous amount of thought into
um but i've never had an issue with it
i've been vaccinated for things as a
child obviously
and there are certain viruses that we've
basically eliminated because of vaccines
however when it comes to the covet
vaccine yes i am a complete anti-vaxxer
i am
very proud that i never got the
experimental injection of the thing that
nobody knew exactly what it was going to
do and it turned out not to do much and
then there all sorts of people have all
had all sorts of complications after
getting the vaccine and by the way it's
not a traditional vaccine it is an mrna
technology which had never been tested
and mass across the world before but
speaking of mrna vax technology who are
these conspiracy theorists that uh the
ceo of pfizer and the head of the world
economic are talking about well it's
people like dr robert malone
who actually owns more patents on the
mrna technology than anyone he was
basically the founder of mrna technology
and of course you guys remember dr
robert malone because he went on joe
rogan to say that this vaccine was
completely out of control and that these
organizations are evil etc etc and then
what happened well the episode got taken
down he got kicked off twitter for three
days everyone ran around saying joe
rogan was racist well dr robert malone
just testified to the texas senate about
the great reset and what these people
are doing this is just a couple days ago
what i believed for a long time had to
be a crazy conspiracy theory
this great reset
that was a book title published by the
head of the world economic forum
four months into the outbreak
that spoke specifically about exploiting
the outbreak for other purposes having
to do with an economic agenda in fact we
should take that seriously that appears
to have been the case it appears to have
been
whether you know all the nuance of
where did the virus come from how is it
generated was it intentionally released
was it inadvertently released all that
stuff is unanswerable
but i believe that when you look at the
data
the information about the policies when
they were implemented
the monetary policies that were
implemented that we're now living with
the consequences of
those data can best be fit as consistent
with
the plans of
a group
of people who had strong economic
interests and it's very difficult for me
to account for the policies that have
been added so last question
okay so there's the guy who basically
invented the mrna technology there's the
guy who went on joe rogan just to
express his views about the vaccines and
mandates and everything else he was
kicked off twitter you all remember this
he was kicked off twitter and then
remember we had that week where everyone
was talking about d-platforming joe
rogan and spotify was going to get rid
of him and people were talking about how
he's racist and needs to be censored and
then it's magically out of nowhere this
video of him saying the n-word appeared
even though he wasn't saying in a
pejorative way you could see how the
machine operates does robert malone
strike you as an alarmist or a
conspiracy theorist or anything else or
is he laying out he's going boy you know
guys there's this book by the by this
guy and in the book they talk about how
we're going to do this great reset and
we can very obviously see how that is
connected to covet and he speaks in a
very very calm manner uh well gina
carrano and you guys remember gina
carano speaking of cancel culture and
people who get uh booted off platforms
for no good reason gina carrano of
course the actress who was in the
mandalorian
she is a conservative she happened to
tweet something uh conservative leaning
she was kicked off the mandalorian
disney plus got rid of her she's now
with the daily wire well she went back
on rogan a couple days ago and they're
still rogan's into this thing now and
they're talking about uh klaus schwab
the world economic forum and how they've
basically installed political leaders
even here right in america and up there
in canada in the world economic forum
then that's bizarre
that's the most bizarre one the [ __ ]
dude who dresses like darth vader
[Laughter]
from the world economic forum he can be
in one of my movies he can bring his own
wardrobe that [ __ ] is wild he's
like a bad guy in a movie
well and then you can have justin
trudeau and gavin newsom right there
with him and it's like you gotta full-on
opportunity was a great reset
okay so
the reason i'm showing you this is
everyone's starting to talk about it i
know not mainstream media right so you
have to forget the layer that protects
the npcs the non-playable characters the
blue and non-people the blue pill people
who will never come around to reality
but everyone on the ground that has one
of these is starting to realize there is
something really weird going on there
when rogan is like yeah this guy who see
sounds like darth vader you know he
dresses like darth vader oh great seth
is coming and it's like this is this is
like a hollywood script this guy and
then what gina's saying there and you
know he could have uh trudeau on one
side a new sim on the other i mean
trudeau is an acolyte of the world
economic forum all of the policies that
he's bringing
to canada right now where they are
cracking down on misinformation
where they are making
all people who report on the news
register with the government where they
are now tracking
what you're doing online in in crazy
ways and i'm sure ways that we have no
idea of
these are ideas of the world economic
forum when you've got uh the netherlands
when you've got the prime minister
suddenly cracking down on his own
farmers who produce food for his
citizens is he doing that because he
thinks it's a great idea or does somehow
klaus schwab have his hands in that like
i know it all sounds nuts but we better
start thinking about this or we're not
going to realize what's going on here
before it's too late and perhaps it's
too late right now or you could also
connect this to a guy like gavin newsom
what has gavin newsom done in california
well you know my feelings on that he has
done everything possible to
intentionally destroy the state and if
you haven't been to california although
i don't recommend anyone go to
california
santa monica in particular because as my
buddy john kept saying when we were
there michael what did he say it smelled
like
urine cakes that's right not just urine
urine is a very specific smell which all
of santa monica smells like that but the
urine cake which is supposed to uh you
know hide the urine smell that's what
santa monica actually smells like more
because they're spraying urine cake
smell all over the urine
sidebar point is uh if you were to go to
california you could drive from say los
angeles socal up north and everywhere in
the farming country which is the bulk of
the middle of california all there are
are farmers with signs saying we cannot
get water uh vote out gavin newsom et
cetera et cetera gavin newsom much like
justin trudeau is instituting policies
that are destroying the place he is
supposed to protect right that's what a
governor is supposed to do you're
supposed to
create the conditions so that your state
or your country uh can flourish and what
justin trudeau has done up in canada we
know canada has tons of people leaving
right now people have absolutely had it
we know the truckers are uprising we
know that uh that all the stuff that
they are doing related to the internet
and everything else this is evil
authoritarian stuff that it was if it
was happening
via say a brown middle eastern leader
right
in an arab country we would be saying
it's the worst possible thing but when
our own guys do it to us we're very
confused uh so trudeau is a great
example of what's going on here
because he is sort of the perfect
example of what the world economic forum
wants out of a leader they want someone
who stands for nothing who's completely
unable to say the truth but who looks
good on camera
who has no real set of beliefs probably
someone who's done blackface like he has
repeatedly because then they can kind of
black uh blackmail him when it comes to
a couple things they can blackface him
again and blackmail him on a couple
things he's a really really bad dude in
case you don't know my feelings about
him but this is a great video so rebel
news you guys know rebel news up in
canada they are doing incredible work up
there it is not easy to be an actual
place of journalism in canada and it's
getting increasingly hard
and if you want more on that you should
watch friday's episode the panel show
with ezra levant who started rebel uh
they have a journalist her name is
alexandra lavoy
and she pushed trudeau on what he's
doing related to vax mandates and just
watch this smug
soulless evil freak
news
um
foreign
what a coward what a disgusting human
being what an awful
world leader and and someone that should
be relegated to the dustbin
of history she asked an extremely
relevant question it is irrelevant what
he feels about rebel now of course the
reason he doesn't like rebel is because
rebel is an independent news
organization in canada and canada funds
news organizations and then you're not
going to believe it they all basically
give trudeau a pass because the
government is funding the news
organizations that's supposed to be
reporting on the politicians so now he's
got one news organization they're
basically the main one that is outside
of the system so they ask him hard
questions and it wasn't just that it was
a hard question it was completely
legitimate question hey vaccines aren't
working uh the way they were promised
you have mandated all of this stuff we
basically had an uprising in the country
because of it you were freezing bank
accounts on people you were throwing
people in jail unjustly we know that
it's not working just look what's
happened in israel
could you comment on that and all he
says is no no i won't i don't like you
he is a horrible horrible human being
there's no other way to put it we have
to start just being clear about what
these people are
but here he is just a bit over a year
ago this is a year and a half ago and he
was singing a very very different tune
when it came to canada and vaccine
mandates
in terms of mandatory vaccines vaccines
won't be mandatory that's not the way we
do things in canada
oh so that's not the way we do things in
canada that was a year and a half ago
then he did a complete 180 started
jailing people freezing bank accounts
demonizing half the country calling them
racists and everything else so what
happened did did justin trudeau have
some incredible political evolution or
is it possible that justin trudeau is
not really the prime minister of canada
meaning that he has canadians interests
at heart is he just a foot soldier or a
stooge for the world economic forum and
klaus schwab and his buddy over there
albert the ceo of pfizer basically we're
like hey dude we want everybody to be
injected and you're going to do it and
he takes orders because he's not he's
just a soulless nothing
and of course by the way he shut down uh
the supply chain when all the truckers
started protesting him then the supply
chain wasn't working
correctly and that's sort of exactly
what's happening in the netherlands
right now as mark rute goes after the
farmers
but you know what happens in western
societies we've still got a chance
because the individual can still stand
up against the system and david can
always beat goliath i firmly believe
that uh the people of canada have had it
with justin trudeau and here he is just
a couple days ago at the calgary
stampede getting heckled great
he's so inauthentic like you know that
hat has never been worn before his shirt
which is tucked in so perfectly as i say
he's just a suit with nice socks there's
nothing authentic about him and you know
i don't love the idea generally that
people should be getting in the faces of
politicians uh certainly in private
places like restaurants and things like
that but if you want to go to a public
place where they're where they're giving
a speech and yell at them at this point
why not at this point why not but this
this vax policy that canada has gone uh
which is clearly ushered in by this
great reset situation uh it has leaked
all over it's not just the netherlands
that's having problems and it's not just
the united states that's having problems
and it's not just canada that's having
problems and much more this has happened
all across the world uh you might have
heard of serbian tennis player a certain
serbian tennis player uh novak djokovic
uh who was banned uh quite often from
many different tournaments during kovid
and nobody really knew why he didn't
want to get vaccine again like many of
these nba players who didn't want to get
vaxxed or some of the other professional
athletes these are usually young guys in
their 20s and 30s who are at the peak of
physical health they just oddly didn't
want an experimental experimental
vaccine to be injected into them so he
was getting banned from tournaments left
and right well now john mcenroe you guys
know john mcenroe even if you're not a
tennis person legendary tennis player
john mcenroe and now broadcaster uh john
mcenroe he went off on the usa in
australia because they're not allowing
djokovic to play because he's unboxed
but now there's the uncertainty it's not
just the majors unfortunately for him
john it's
any tennis server where is he going to
play next
and be able to play in north well i hope
this is
open
it's a great moment these politicians
are getting the way uh too much they did
it in australia let's let the guy come
in and play the in the us i mean come on
this is ridiculous
but
i don't make those decisions i hope that
someone makes the right one and allows
him to play
so do you think any of this has to do
with logic or reason or anything else
djokovic right there who's basically
been the best tennis player probably for
like in the world probably for about a
decade young guy right there incredible
athlete incredible athlete peak physical
condition right to be a tennis player at
that level he's not sick and even if he
was sick you're allowed to make choices
over your body i thought it was my body
my choice right but for some reason the
united states and australia won't let
him play in these tournaments john
mcenroe gets it but we need more and
more people to get it so now let's bring
this back to the united states we have
joe biden as president he is the elderly
man pretending to be president
and even though when he was running for
president he said there would be known
mandates as you know once he became
president he was not only four mandates
uh he wanted to fire frontline workers
doctors nurses airline pilots uh all
sorts of people if they did not get
vaccinated and he wanted to force
private companies to do whatever the
hell it was he wanted here's a blast
from the past
this is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
my job as president is to protect all
americans
so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week
already i've announced we'll be
requiring vaccinations at all nursing
home workers
who treat patients on medicare and
medicaid because i have that federal
authority
tonight i'm using that same authority
to expand that to cover those who work
in hospitals
home health care facilities or other
medical facilities
a total of 17 million health care
workers if you're seeking care
at a health facility
you should be able to know
that the people treating you are
vaccinated simple straightforward period
next
i will sign an executive order that will
now require all executive branch federal
employees to be vaccinated all
okay so fortunately most of that stuff
got reversed and companies realized that
they did not have a right
an osha violation that's what they were
worried about this is going to be a
violation of osha osha's going to come
get us
they did not have a right to tell their
employees what to be vaccinated with i
although i don't have 100 employees the
idea that i could at any point say to
anyone that worked for me you have to be
injected with this is insane you know
we're going to the marlins game tonight
taking the team out we're doing a little
team building that's what we're doing
tonight we're going to the marlins game
what right would i have to say you have
to get chicken fingers tonight you guys
might want hot dogs it's a ball game you
want hot dogs you want cracker jacks
right i can't tell people to have
chicken fingers but that is the
stupidity that these people have pushed
on us and i get it biden's just a shell
of a human being and he just reads
what's put in front of him but what
better leader would there be if you were
if you were a bad evil conglomerate
trying to run the world if you were the
legion of doom if i can do a super
friends reference for you you know if
you were the bad guys i know that's a dc
reference for some of you comic book
people but if you were the legion of
doom and you wanted to take over the
world what kind of leaders would you
want in the countries you would want hey
how about a elderly man with dementia
who has no ability to think for himself
who can barely read the teleprompter
that would be a pretty one pretty good
one because you can just get him out
there to say whatever you want who maybe
is being blackmailed because his son was
a crack addict with prostitutes and the
mainstream media is covering up for that
you might want that how about a guy who
just stands for nothing and believes in
nothing but looks good in front of the
camera justin trudeau you think that
might work how about the guy who uh the
head of the whole thing world economic
forum klaus schwab says is super hands
he and he just likes his ego strokes so
he'll shut down farming in his country
uh but you know what guys the thing is a
bunch of us are seeing it now and that's
good
but the thing is it is very obvious that
they are now making it clear that they
will going forward use covid as a
political weapon that it will be the
thing that any time too many of us get
too uppity and say too much and start
thinking too much they will just bring
covid back here is biden's health and
homeland security
chief xavier becerra we've shown you
some videos from him saying that the
virus is coming back yeah it's coming
back this is just yesterday what i will
tell you is that
come the fall and winter
most everyone who's uh an expert on
pandemics and
these viruses will tell you the strong
chance that we see we'll see a
resurgence of the virus whether it's the
variants that we have now or new
variants and we've got to be ready
it's just meaningless drivel right like
who's saying this who's saying that it
has to come back in the fall and even if
it does come back who's saying that they
have the right to tell any of us what to
do or get injected or wear a mask or
whatever but there is something else
happening in the fall that i know is
happening in the fall that i'm pretty
sure is happening in the fall that i
believe is happening the first week of
november which is right in the middle of
the fall
the midterm elections
do you think that they might want to
bring back covet in the midterm
elections and make sure that you do
mail-in balloting and ballot harvesting
and no ids and all of those things do
you see what's going on here am i a
crazy conspiracy theorist or am i just
the guy with his head on somewhat
straight i think you know the answer but
why
ladies and gentlemen why would they
bring covet back so that they can have
their election shenanigans is there
something that they're trying to protect
some sort of world order it's not like
they would say that right in front of us
would they because that would be nuts to
just say it like on tv to say that
you're protecting some sort of world
order that would be bananas so they said
that this could be a long a war measured
in years and i think everybody
understands why
this is happening but is it sustainable
what do you say to those families who
say listen we can't afford to pay 4.85 a
gallon for months if not years this is
just not sustainable
well what you heard from the president
today was a clear articulation of the
stakes this is about the future of the
liberal world order and we have to stand
firm
oh
i can't believe it i was just kidding i
can't believe that somebody would go on
cnn and admit that they've got some sort
of world order that you have to pay more
for you have to not leave your house as
much you have to be injected for so that
they can maintain their liberal world
order what the hell are they talking
about and of course that guy right there
uh who's biden's national economic
council chairman his name is brian diese
you're not going to believe this guys
it's just crazy man i should have a tin
foil hat on today i have a i should have
a very very special tinfoil hat uh he is
a former employee of blackrock i know
it's just absolutely nuts so who do we
oppose who do we oppose and how do we
push back on all of this nonsense
because we know that you know if you say
any of these things they'll say you're a
racist you're a bigot you're a
conspiracy theorist we gotta ban you on
twitter and all of these things because
you're a mean dude you're a mean dude
you don't like klaus schwab you know and
he's a good dude we got to defend the
liberal world order we got to make sure
farmers can't farm and truckers can't
truck and a whole bunch of other stuff
well then that brought me to this clip
this was a rather extraordinary clip
tucker carlson was interviewed by this
guy ben smith now he works at the new
york times now uh he's a former i think
he was the ceo of buzzfeed this guy is
a smear merchant and and so many of the
things that are wrong with the internet
right now come out of you'll see this
guy he's a sweaty smarmy mess
and just like a squirrely little nothing
but he ran buzzfeed for many many years
and buzzfeed you remember although
remember all those years of buzzfeed it
seems like a long time ago where people
all day long would be sharing those
things on buzzfeed where you just click
things all day long do you like this ice
cream more than cookies but you click
and i honestly believe
that they were basically just tracking
all of our behaviors all along buzzfeed
was never anything that made money when
they went public it crashed because
there was really nothing there well
anyway he ran buzzfeed buzzfeed is pure
trash but what happens in the leftist
media if you run something that's trash
and you do horrible things you move on
up so he works with new york times right
now and he interviewed tucker carlson
and the reason i'm linking this to all
of this is tucker has been one of the
most and probably the only
mainstream media voice who has been
talking about the great reset talking
about all of this globalist stuff i mean
yes there are people that are not
mainstream anywhere glenn beck would be
the best example of it but i'm talking
about fox news you know on cable news
type person talking about this stuff so
ben smith interviewed tucker and mostly
it was you know tucker you're a freaking
racist
do you think that white some claim on
america that people of other races do of
course not i mean first of all i'm a
christian so i think god made everybody
and therefore everyone has equal value
in his eyes that's
the essential value of every person is
the same
but the idea that i harbor some sort of
deep racial animus
is like i mean i i think there are a lot
of criticisms you could level at me
i think sometimes i overstate case i get
pissed i can be very nasty you've been
on the receiving end of that i know you
can vouch for that
but the idea that i'm a you know that i
i mean if if you were to look at my
texts or listen to my personal
conversations or read my mind
you would find
no instance or i'm like i'm mad at black
people
100
of the people that i'm mad at
are
well educated white liberals in my mind
the sort of archetype the person i don't
like is like a 38 year old female white
lawyer with the barren personal life
that's who yells at me on airplanes and
so i always think people are like you're
racist okay let me let before okay let
let me
we are not mad at black people like what
are you talking about can
so you see why i showed you that video
because it's slightly
not on this topic but it actually is
once you peel off one layer because
tucker is the main push back against all
of these people these people that have
nothing
that that clown ben smith knows that
tucker carlson is not a racist i would
not befriend a racist i wouldn't go on
the show of a racist uh tucker does not
want there to be different laws for
black people and tucker does not want
there to be different laws for gay
people which
hating gay people is a form of racism i
think too according to these people
intersectionality it makes weird bad
fellows
but it's all that they've got all that
they've got is oh you somehow are
stoking white outrage now the funny
thing about it is they're the ones that
are stoking white outrage all the time
they're the ones who are always talking
about why privilege and how evil white
people are and the patriarchy and all
those things and then they turn to the
other people who are saying hey that's
that's not true and we don't like
identity politics and all that and they
and then they say to them hey hey you
just said something and you're the
racist even though they're the one
pushing the racism on all of us uh and
and i think that this is what the left
gets wrong about their political
opposition and that's why they're losing
i think that there is this huge swath of
people and you are right in the thick of
it if you watch this show
that are not extremists by any stretch
that are not probably not the most
traditional republicans or conservatives
you're certainly not racist you're most
likely not homophobic homophobic
you might be homophobic because you've
lived in california long enough and the
amount of hobos there you could
eventually well wouldn't a phobia is an
irrational fear it would at some point
become a rational fear um but we are not
racist but what tucker said right there
is right who is pushing all of this on
us so you've got the the globalist layer
but within america right now it's the
overly educated white liberals i don't
even mean to bring skin color into this
but it it's the elizabeth warrens it's
the bernie sanders it's everything that
comes out of harvard and yale it's these
people
who should know better they should know
better and be appreciative of everything
that is good in america
because their ancestors had to fight so
hard for it but it's klaus schwab it's
that guy brian diese it's mark rutte
it's all of these really hyper-educated
elite people and why would
hyper-educated elite people want
everybody else to think that they were
racist and why would they want everyone
else to be afraid to say what they want
online because perhaps
perhaps all they're really trying to do
is hold on to power
and people have power when they realize
it do you think that might be it uh but
and fear not guys uh there is hope and
why is there hope because everyone as
i've been illustrating for the last week
and a half the biden thing is falling
apart
fast and the faster it falls apart here
that will be the signal for other
countries for people to realize hey
justin trudeau is not going to be there
forever canada is more important than
him and the netherlands is more
important than this world economic
stooge
here is biden failing to shut down that
virus he promised he was going to shut
down
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm not gonna shut down the country but
i'm gonna shut down the virus i'm gonna
shut down the virus i'm gonna shut down
the virus i will take care of this i
will end this i will make sure we have a
plan i'm gonna shut down the virus i'll
shut down the virus i'm going to shut
down the virus what i would say is i'm
going to shut down the virus i'm going
to shut down the virus look there is no
federal solution this gets solved at the
state level
ah gets solved at a state level sort of
like that orange man was trying to do
the entire time the orange man who you
guys called hitler who said ah i don't
think i should have all this power let
the states deal with it of course only
four hundred thousand people died under
trump uh when it came to kova nearly 600
under and so he obviously is not very
good at any of this and again when he's
reading these things he just doesn't
even know what he's saying he has no
idea what he's saying uh but here's
biden back in december
and this is what it really comes down to
because it comes down to these upcoming
midterms
and he's warning republicans that that
people you know
midterms are coming in you're
republicans republicans are mean
now we look at 2022.
i want to tell my republican friends get
ready bal you're going in for a problem
and we need to stay unified
conor i want you to put that video in a
special vault and i want the day after
the red wave the
destruction of the democratic party
although again gotta give the devil his
due covet could come back they could
drop a nuclear bomb these people are
freaks zombie apocalypse alien invasion
you never know what it might be but
barring any of those things
that's the video we're playing the day
after the election uh but all right
let's keep moving on this idea that
people are getting it nobody's buying
biden's [ __ ] anymore no one's buying
it here's cnn jake tappering company
realizing that nobody
should be a sitcom nobody likes joe
nearly two-thirds of democratic primary
voters want a different nominee
two-thirds if you break it down by age
94 of democratic primary voters under
the age of 30
94
say they don't want biden that is a
stunning number
yes um
he swept his grandchildren but other
than that i mean like who uh
i mean 94 percent don't want him or damn
again
democrats under the age of 30. what was
the president's response to a new poll
from the new york times today showing
that 64 of democrats say that they would
prefer a different candidate in 2024 and
um i would also say from that very same
poll
um there were 92 percent of uh
any political and now polls are going to
go up but they're going to go down uh
this is not the thing that we are solely
focused on
okay so first off let me do the second
half first that's corinne sean pierre of
course you know her she's the black
lesbian press secretary uh she
completely lied there and by the way do
you know that their new line have you
noticed this we played a clip of gay
pete yesterday uh that their new line is
i'm not gonna do politics from here i'm
at the podium with the presidential seal
behind me i'm not going to do politics
here i'm being interviewed by someone
and i'm the transportation secretary i'm
not going to do politics here it's so
obvious their game man the curtain has
just been pulled back people but that
number that 94
of young democrats don't under 30 don't
want biden to run they do not like joe
biden who is supporting joe biden right
now other than the globalists the elite
the media
who is walking around going joe biden's
doing a heck of a job i feel really good
about the economy i feel good about the
supply chain i feel good about the war
not war half war going on in ukraine
russia i feel good about the way we left
afghanistan and i haven't noticed
anything wrong with joe biden's brain
everything's just fine
no
everyone can see it now what's
interesting as tapper and his panel
laugh about that it's like jake you
ushered this [ __ ] in people like to
think that you're the sort of moderate
on cnn meaning you're not completely
insane and a completely totally obvious
democrat operative say like jim acosta
or brian stelter you're supposed to be a
little more or both but you obviously
wanted uh joe biden to be president you
obviously wanted to get rid of trump and
now you're all realizing it and and when
the rats are getting off the ship you
know something's wrong so
we have an opportunity guys we have an
opportunity despite that alien invasion
that i'm predicting despite the zombie
apocalypse and the rest of it we just
got to stay focused know what they're
doing stay calm
and and i think we can get to the other
side of this thing i really do
uh boy this might be our longest show
ever guys yes i'm getting the thumbs up
56 minutes unscripted
people that's what we're doing around
here okay
let's get to some
reubenreport.locals.com
uh comments and then i will leave you
with a cold clothes kathy says klaus
schwab is like a bond villain status
would be comical if he wasn't so
sinister yeah he comes off as basically
like a comic book villain or a bond
villain and it and that's what i'm
saying it's almost like how is this even
possible i think that's almost part of
it they found the guy the accent is
perfect for the evil every the way he
dresses everything is perfect for the
evil so it's like so obvious we kind of
can't see it it's like no he can't be
that possibly evil the world economic
forum and the global you can't if this
is two the writing's not even good
enough it's too flat give me something
layered man
nuclear patrick says rutay has told
farmers to cut back on one third of
their livestock i mean it's
extraordinary to say you got to get rid
of 50 of emissions in eight years cut
back on the livestock and the rest of it
do you think he honestly believes that
is the best policy for the netherlands
or is there something else going on here
much like happened with the truckers i
mean it's absolutely just crazy i would
recommend to everybody if you've got a
tiny bit of land or if you've got a
freaking little pot grow a little
something grow a little something we're
growing some avocados here we've got
some mangoes here tomatoes although
they're tough to grow in the summer
and if you can you know get a chicken
coop or whatever it's like these systems
are not quite working and don't think
that these people wouldn't tear it all
down in the quest to maintain that power
i know i know it sounds nuts i'd rather
talk about something else but here we
are
amy says i don't think for one second
these higher up elites actually took the
vaccine that's an interesting one well
you know they always show you the videos
of biden with his hairy arm getting
injected and he doesn't know where he is
or what he's doing or what's going on
it's like who knows what they did they
they get i don't even know
but man yesterday's conspiracy theorists
are tomorrow's truth so here we are
guys uh i've enjoyed this program how'd
i do today guys
you know what
you're all getting chicken fingers at
the baseball game tonight regardless of
your own personal culinary preferences
chicken fingers and fries for everybody
at the baseball game uh you can join us
if you want to play along during the
show at reubenreport.locals.com part one
of my interview with patrick bett david
from valuetainment the guy's really
brilliant especially on the economic
side of things uh is up on uh rumble and
youtube right now full things already up
on locals of course and finally we leave
you with this cold close which is
similar to our opening today our cold
opening was dr jill biden who is
pandering beyond belief to the latinx
community there are more latinos in this
diverse community than tacos and
burritos and enchiladas and chimichangas
but you know what someone was doing it
even better before her
enjoy
no more questions they said no she has
to go what's something that you always
carry with you hot sauce
really yeah yeah really are you getting
information right now
hot sauce in my bag swag that's us
really yes now listen i just want you to
know people are going to see this and
say okay she's painted in the black
people
okay
is it working